I already got my paperwork in captain
then I guess those little reminders of
you Wow
looks like he hates you even more than
me what doesn't we have a good
relationship we're on the same page
something that share with the rest of us
it's not doable no sir I wasn't Parata
was the one that was talking guide you
must been the worst fourth grader ever
joke's on you
I skipped fourth grade Santiago anything
else no mm-hmm I am psyched to go on
this week-long cruise just sitting
around doing nothing
straight up living that slug life y'all
cruise itineraries hot off the laminator
who's ready for some non-stop totally
scheduled fun oh I actually thought we
could just sit by the pool you'd
unlimited shrimp and see what it does to
our bodies that's cute I don't know if
there's gonna be time though the cruise
offers 77 activities and I signed us up
for 76 of them hey guys Department has a
new green initiative we have to reduce
energy usage by 15% that means no more
laminating Santiago oh that's fine not
the thing that gives me the most
pleasure in life interacting with other
people that's what gets me going this
field trip has to go well this is my
chance to impress the principal Sarge
you're in luck I went to a magnet school
where I was voted most likely to
befriend a school administrator I mean I
love paperwork but this is crazy there
wasn't even time to savor it Charles
you're going too fast I don't have a
choice we can't let this place for
fellowship perps yeah but you're gonna
cramp you kiddin baby I've been cramming
for the past 20 minutes so attracted
yeah I know how to solve this we just
have to find out which football player
had third period with Brandon bliss we
need to class schedule yeah but where
are we gonna find that in the coolest
room in the school
or you could have just picked the lock
I'm sorry I'm just so amped up about
admin 300 call number in the fine arts
section what is this Beirut you know you
don't work here you don't have to be
shelf the books well someone has to I'm
so sorry I'm just really stressed out
you're a great librarian and I'm sure
you're not the one who shelled this
section I am God Debbie what is going on
with you
Papa's a gentleman he won't propose
until he gets Gina's blessing and she
won't give it to him
who says Papa are you little French boy
I think maybe I can help I took a
seminar on conflict resolution and I
have been waiting weeks to bust this bad
boy out hmm
new binder smell mm-hmm Amy don't do
this i'ma throw a milkshake in your face
hi detective Santiago magnet school
alumna I appreciate that you use the
proper declension of alumnus well some
say Latin is a dead language but I say
it's just taking a long nap okay we have
got to explain this thing to captain
Holt to save their relationship and you
laughed at me when I went to that
weekend long math conference because you
called it funky cats and they're feisty
Stef's that was the name it was so cool
it was not anyway it's not about the
math they haven't seen each other
because of the night shift I just need a
bone what gross Rosa those are our dads
I mean that's not what I think captain
dad is just my boss Wow never mind I'm
Gigi father the math whatever Rosa
oh that's a nice lamb job this one goes
on the blog mmm hey Sarge
what up bro what up bro you're
laminating in here aren't you I'm sorry
I just loved it so much that concludes
our briefing now on a personal note I
have some thoughts about Beyonce's
lemonade I'd like to share oh my god sir
as much as I want to hear those thoughts
and it is so so much I think we should
probably let Amy speak oh sorry I'll go
the floor is yours thank you okay here's
everyone's itineraries for Thanksgiving
at my place I know a lot of your
families are out of town and you just
want to relax but I think we'll all
enjoy ourselves more if we rigidly stick
to the schedule
whoa did you assign us individual
bathroom break times keep asking
questions about it starch and your slot
is after Scully's hi Santiago down your
toilet there's no way you're using a
keyboard with your hands like that oh I
could help you not to brag but at typing
camp everyone called me the finger queen
oh my god that sounds really dirty I
swear that's not what it meant hey
Santiago you know why you didn't get
into Sam Sam probably because I used a
modern format on my cover letter that
put my email above my home address why
take such a risk the two hunks have
arrived so glad to have you here dad
happy to be here how was your flight oh
good yeah I did the times Kosovo oh
great puzzle today right oh my god 17
down I know what about 16 across what
about 34 cross what about 45 down what
about 20 across I also did it yeah
astronomy is full of interesting facts
for instance here's one that Hollywood
doesn't want you to know a parsec is
actually a measure of distance one of
the many inaccuracies in the Star Wars
universe mm-hmm and was Star Wars oh boy
maybe I'm getting ahead of myself
okay let's talk planets Jupiter is a gas
giant
so such [ __ ] how does this help me it
also has 67 moons I came up with a fun
mnemonic device to remember them all it
goes every individual gets crayons after
telling his aggressive
Mongoose painter called Ernests some
lies about tiny panda heads period maybe
one kid could take her elephant into
California except where's Gina she told
me you call me a gas giant
well now you and I will never hook up
you wanted to see me captain
yes the DA wanted me to personally thank
you for your work on the Jay Street drug
bust that's why we do this sir for
praise hey can I take a couple photos of
your desk I want to submit them to
organizers quarterly work there's a
magazine about organizing yeah I want to
be featured as organizer of the month
just imagine me on the cover with tons
of scarves lying around and holding them
up like this is too many scarves we got
to do something okay oh now can you open
the drawers if you want to get featured
you gotta show him what's under the
skirt know what I mean I'm gonna
dominate that class you don't cross
stitch for 20 years without developing a
steady hand
wow you really think that's a brag don't
you 20 bucks says I do better in that
class than you do
it's the redhead all right you're on
I'll have you know that the redhead is a
glowing compliment in the sewing
community if you wanted to insult me
should have called me a stitch skipper
kristef skipper no I handed it to you
all right Ames let's go over your cover
story again okay my name is Isabel
Cortez I'm in for murder because some
perv on the subway tried to touch me and
I was like did someone order a
tracheotomy okay I think that's a little
too technical we need to work on your
tough talk okay
first the good news I generated a
detailed timeline broken down to
30-second increments to keep us on track
the bad news we're already 16.5
increments behind schedule yeah Terry
feels overwhelmed good use it Neil
Armstrong was overwhelmed when he walked
on the moon but you know what he did he
walked on the moon okay this is the
Junior police program
aka Mission Possible
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to get your life back on track
my bathroom break during a test took a
little longer than anticipated
may I use the restroom please nothing
we'll see ya excuse me little disk
that's why they say it's test time so
diaper up
they say that I've never said that I've
never worn a diaper during a test you
would wear a diaper during it does
that's ridiculous
thank you sorry how do you want me to
proceed figure it out Santiago it's your
case yes I will do that thank you
are you bowing no this is how I walk
okay I've got something oh that's not
Brandon's profile it's mine I just want
a quick peek at your attendance record
zero absences oh mama
printing this for later all right keep
it in your pants Santiago oh that's
exactly where it's going it's not the
turnout I was hoping for maybe I should
offer free strudel then at least Scully
would have come there's free strudel
what did you go from I don't get it
I am shocked that more people wouldn't
want the tutelage of our precincts nay
our city's most esteemed sergeant what
do you want Santiago to learn the
majestic art of self-defense from our
cities may our country a little man out
with it now all we need is the death
certificate officially notarized you
want me to break the sacred oath I took
to become a notary it's not a problem
cuz I'm a badass just like Rosa so I am
going to stamp this and violate my oath
you keep talking but we're done here
hold hasn't seen Kevin in like months
and I was just thinking if that was me
and you it would make me really sad no
that's actually super sweet plus there's
this big fat binder full of instructions
and words there's a binder why didn't
you lead with that you idiot I'm gonna
just leave you two alone
you